si vous l’employez pour un an, nous paierons la moitié de son salaire.
Le but était de s'assurer que chaque toxicomane
ait quelque chose qui le motive.
Lorsque j'y suis allé et que j'ai vu les toxicomanes au Portugal,
ce qu'ils ont dit, c'est qu'en redécouvrant un sens à leur vie
ils redécouvraient des liens et des relations.
Ça fera 15 ans cette année que l'expérience a débuté,
et les résultats sont là :
l'injection de drogue est en baisse au Portugal,
selon le British Journal of Criminology,
de 50%, la moitié.
L'overdose est en baisse massive, le VIH est en baisse entre les toxicomanes.
La dépendance a baissé de façon significative.
Pour savoir que ça a bien marché, il suffit de voir que
presque personne là-bas ne veut revenir à l'ancien système.
Ce sont les implications politiques.
Je crois vraiment qu'il y a des implications en dessous de ça.
Nous vivons dans une culture où les gens se sentent de plus en plus vulnérables
à toutes sortes de dépendances, que ce soit aux smartphones,
au shopping ou à la nourriture.
Avant que ces conversations ne débutent, vous savez ça,
on nous a interdit d'avoir nos smartphones allumés,
et je dois dire, beaucoup d'entre vous ressemblaient à
des toxicomanes à qui on avait dit que leur dealer ne serait pas disponible
pendant 2 heures. (Rires)
Beaucoup d'entre nous ressentent ça, et ça peut être bizarre --
j'ai dit que la déconnexion est la cause majeure de l'addiction
et bizarrement ça augmente,
alors que notre société n'a jamais été aussi connectée.
Mais j'ai commencé à croire que les connexions que l'on a,
ou que l'on pense avoir, sont une sorte de parodie de l'expérience humaine.
Si vous avez une crise dans votre vie vous remarquerez une chose.
Ce ne sera pas ceux sur Twitter qui viendront s'asseoir avec vous.
Ce ne sera pas vos amis de Facebook qui vous remettront sur pied.
Ce sera ceux en chair et en os avec qui vous avez un lien
profond, nuancé et texturé, en face-à-face.
J'ai entendu parler d'une étude de Bill McKibben, écrivain environnementaliste,
qui, je crois, en dit long de ce phénomène.
Il a regardé le nombre d'amis proches que l'Américain moyen croit
pouvoir appeler en cas de crise.
Ce nombre baisse régulièrement depuis les années 50.
Le taux de surface habitable qu'un individu possède chez lui
augmente de façon constante,
et je crois que c'est métaphoriquement
le choix de notre culture.
Nous avons troqué la surface contre des amis des choses contre des liens sociaux.
La conséquence : notre société est l'une des plus solitaires qui ait existé.
Bruce Alexander, qui a fait l'expérience du Rat Park, dit que
nous parlons tout le temps du rétablissement individuel,
et c'est juste de parler comme ça,
mais nous devrions parler de la guérison sociale.
Nous avons mal tourné, pas seulement au niveau individuel mais aussi en groupe
et nous avons créé une société où, pour la majorité,
la vie ressemble bien plus à cette cage isolée
et bien moins à Rat Park.
Si je suis honnête, ce n'est pas la raison pour laquelle je m'y suis intéressé.
Je ne cherchais pas à découvrir l'aspect politique, l'aspect social.
Je voulais savoir comment aider les gens que j'aime.
Et quand je suis revenu de ce long périple, que j'avais appris tout ça
j'ai regardé les toxicomanes dans ma vie,
et si vous êtes très sincère, c'est dur d'aimer un toxicomane.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui savent ça dans cette pièce.
Vous êtes tout le temps en colère,
et je crois que l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ce débat est si lourd,
c'est parce qu'il touche au cœur chacun d'entre nous, non ?
Chacun à une part de lui qui regarde un toxicomane et pense
qu'il voudrait qu'on l'en empêche.
Et ces histoires qu'on nous raconte pour gérer les toxicomanes dans nos vies
sont caractérisées
par l'émission de téléréalité Intervention.
Je crois que nos vies sont définies par la téléréalité
mais c'est un autre TEDTalk.
Si vous avez vu l'émission,
c'est un postulat plutôt simple.
Prenez un toxico et toutes ses connaissances, rassemblez-les,
confrontez-les avec ce qu'ils font, dites-leur de se reprendre en main,
sinon on coupe les ponts.
Ils prennent les relations des drogués,
ils les menacent, les rendent contingentes aux comportements des toxicomanes.
Et j'ai commencé à réfléchir, à voir pourquoi cette approche ne marche pas,
c'est presque comme importer la logique de la guerre contre la drogue
dans nos vies privées.
Alors j'ai pensé, comment pourrais-je être Portugais ?
Ce que j'ai essayé de faire, je ne vous dis pas de le faire constamment,
je ne peux pas dire que c'est facile,
est de dire aux dépendants dans ma vie
que je veux approfondir notre connexion,
leur dire, je t'aime, que tu consommes ou non,
je t'aime, peu importe ton état,
si tu as besoin de moi, je viendrais m'asseoir avec toi
parce que je t'aime et je ne veux pas que tu sois seul
ou que tu te sentes seul.
Et je crois que le cœur de ce message —
vous n'êtes pas seuls, nous vous aimons —
doit être à chaque étape de notre réaction face aux toxicomanes,
socialement, politiquement et individuellement.
Nous avons chanté des chants de guerre à propos des toxicomanes pendant 100 ans.
Je crois que, depuis le début,
nous aurions dû leur chanter des chansons d'amour,
parce que le contraire de la dépendance n'est pas la sobriété.
Le contraire de la dépendance est la connexion.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)